this footage was taken a few years ago
when the Nord Stream pipeline was still
under construction so far it hasn't
carried much natural gas from Russia to
Germany the supply contracts are
long-term and fixed at this moment this
is where Europe's natural gas is coming
from Germany buys about 37 percent of
its gas from Russia supplies enter the
country via the North Stream pipeline
and two other pipes from the East
countries in the other parts of the
European Union on average cover only
about 30 percent of their natural gas
needs with Russian deliveries the
conflict in Ukraine has heated up as has
EU criticism of Russian President
Vladimir Putin in order to put him under
more pressure to defuse the situation
the bloc is looking for fast ways to
reduce dependence on Russian gas in one
scenario Norway could begin to play a
more important role as an exporter a
terminal for liquid gas that's long been
in planning could also go into operation
on Germany's North Sea coast the net
effect of those moves could reduce
Russian imports to just 25% of the whole
but they would be expensive and experts
are skeptical Norwegian reserves also
have their limits we won't be able to
replace a major Russian contribution
through Norwegian gas either in the
short or the long term
that's impossible building the liquid
gas facility is an option but comes with
a hefty price tag it takes time to
construct the big terminals you need for
liquid gas depart and at the moment they
wouldn't be profitable that means we
would have to build them with state
funds and I think that's not likely to
happen to us
howdy standoff video inversion
another possible scenario would be a
much more radical approach the German
government could speed up plans to
convert to renewables insulate buildings
and even allow fracking this is
realistic in northern Germany in
particular which has reserves of shale
gas Germany would also have to improve
relations with Iran and restart the
Nabucco pipeline project to bring gas
from Iran and the Caspian Sea in the
long run that could reduce Germany's
dependence on Russian exports to just
10% but prices would rise due to the
necessary investments I think that would
work in fact I think Iran is waiting and
hoping for it today
until now other countries have been
involved in developing Iran's major
natural gas reserves but there's no
reason no Geographic reason why Germany
could not also become a training partner
in this market if the situation with
Iran improved Honda's popular of them
got smoked the move that has real
potential to make us more independent of
Russian gas is improving energy
efficiency in buildings in my view
that's the answer that we are looking
for good but once the conflict in
Ukraine has been resolved in relations
with Russia are back on an even keel the
pressure to change will drop things
would then stay more or less the same
experts say this third scenario is the
most likely in it long-term supply
contracts with Russia would be adhered
to and may be renewed Germany's
dependence on Russian natural gas would
even rise slightly to around 40% of
course the gas would have to remain
cheap this is certainly the most
probable option even throughout the Cold
War Russia remained one of our gas
suppliers and it is also dependent on
the income it receives for gas exports
to Germany so that in the end I think
Putin is very interested in keeping
things just as they are but none of
these scenarios will happen anytime soon
little can change in fact for at least
10 years for the immediate future
Germany will remain dependent on Russian
natural gas
you